what's up everybody Zaki here with geek
culture giving you another unboxing and
you guessed it this is the one piece
Odyssey collector's edition now all you
enemy and manga fans will have a lot to
look forward to at the start of 2023 as
one piece Odyssey is set to launch on
the PlayStation 4 PlayStation 5 Xbox One
and Xbox series X and S not to mention a
PC on January 13th speaking of a PC why
not play One Piece Odyssey on an MSR
laptop this video is brought to you by
MSI meet the summit e16 flip featuring
the latest 12th gen Intel Core i7
processor RTX 30 series graphics and a
16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the Sony e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime let's go ahead and
unbox this this is what the packaging
looks like this is in the shape of a
cube with some artwork because these
cubes are part of the game's story it's
very interesting very symbolic of sorts
of course there are items here right and
let's unbox this first we have the
PlayStation 5 copy of One Piece Odyssey
here's the back let's open this up see
that there's the PlayStation 5 disc of
course we also have the collectors
edition bonuses and Adventure expansion
pack sniper king outfit set and 100
000 berries we also have the early
purchase bonus content with the
traveling outfit set featuring the straw
hat Pirates clothes from two years ago
you can wear the traveling outfit from
Luffy Zorro Nami yusop Sanji Chopper and
Robin there's also a Ultra useful
accessory set
which is 10 energy apples 10 excite
apples three golden jellies and 100 000
berries as well as two jewelries a drop
rate up petite jewelry and HP conversion
petite jewelry which will be used in
game now moving forward we also have
some postcards so the postcards we have
is of course Nami and you see in the
foreground is the straw hat Pirates
we've also got Ace over here and we also
have Luffy and Shanks there so these
three postcards are reminiscent of the
manga and the enemy that you've probably
seen if you're a one-piece fan and there
will be flashbacks of these particular
moments in the game as well so you guys
can look forward to that very nice cool
next up we also have the one piece
Odyssey steelbook case a collectible
steelbook case with the same symbols we
have now from what I know these symbols
reflect a new mysterious island that the
straw hat Pirates will be facing in the
game so it alludes to something if you
will very nice is it opened up you have
some artwork as well
very interesting
safety two and of course the peace
dollar resistance is the one piece
Odyssey exclusive diorama which I'm
trying to get out here carefully well if
you can see inside the box it's also
decorated with the artwork as well so
I'm assuming you can actually unfold
this and get a nice background see
whether we can do that there you go
see that
that's pretty gnarly that's cool I like
to keep the Box guys it's a very nice
box
to house everything inside so what we
have here are the mysterious cubes again
we got Luffy prepared for a battle and
we also have the new character that you
will be playing called Lim
not sure what she's holding so let's
check it out let's go and figure this
out guys I am as curious as you and look
what it looks it's all in one piece I
get it I can't believe I just made that
up I don't think there's anything to
install
yet
more tape surrounding the box to be
extra safe here
let's do this let's get that out and
there you go wow that was the easiest
unboxing I ever had carry that out folks
looks even nicer than what is shown on
the box
Luffy here battle pose
right not as 2D as you would see it
holding like a
clear
bottle of thoughts interesting
so as the cubes
it's got a half to it too
I wonder what it's made of definitely
resin just not sure what type of resin
you know what's better than just showing
it to you like this an epic b-roll
Montage y'all
foreign
[Music]
everybody thank you for watching this
video this is the one piece Odyssey
collectors edition hope you guys enjoyed
this it's a very short and simple video
but you guys can expect to clock in 40
to 60 hours of gameplay just this game
this is going to be amazing folks and
with that do consider subscribing and
giving us a like as well goes a long way
thank you for watching and we'll see you
in the next one
[Music]